[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
i'm heather ruse and I'm Ayanna wave and
this is your news for Monday November 27
we're gonna start off with some casting
news that we heard this week first of
all Jude Law is going to be joining the
cast of Captain Marvel and it's been
semi confirmed that he's going to be
playing the villain Marvel so we'll just
have to it's not 100% confirmed mostly
confirmed but he's joining the cast and
more good folks joining in Captain
Marvel I'm excited to see this movie
you've all got some busy stuff coming up
but everything is great just hitting all
those nerd movies absolutely another
casting news gambits movie which is
first I'm still so happy they announced
that Lizzy Caplan is going to be joining
the cast as the female lead we have no
other ideas asked you her character that
even that kind of tightly under wraps so
I doubt we're gonna hear anything
anytime soon about who she will be
playing maybe something will leak but I
doubt it right now all we have a
speculation the female lead yeah of a
gambit movie good could be home any
choice I mean it Cumberbatch first Star
Trek guys kind like everyone just like
its Khan right it's kind there was no
god yeah speaking of Channing Tatum
thinks he has a new animated movie
coming out that we saw the trailer for
this week called small foot a Channing
Tatum plays a Yeti and he's sort of
telling a campfire story to some yogurt
yetis about the mysterious humans with
their tiny feet it looks really funny
and cute actually it looks cute I kind
of see that yeah it looks like a fun
family movie
absolutely no probably another trailer
that we got this week that I am very
excited for is we finally got a trailer
for The CW crossover event crisis on
Earth X and it's happening tonight with
Supergirl and I cannot wait I'll be live
tweeting the whole thing so we saw in
the trailer the bad guys crashing the
wedding
berry and irises wedding and it's not
these it's officially not the bad guys
just as a reminder yeah so it looks like
it's gonna be crazy it seems like
there's been a lot of passion put into
this project and a couple of the
articles I read we're comparing it to
the Justice League almost it looks like
it's gonna be a team-up of that kind of
scale and magnitude a true crossover
because I know for the past couple of
years the CW crossover events have been
like they've been fine they've been good
but it's been over maybe one or two
shows shows - like all definitely going
to encompass all of them the footage
looked really good I have to admit I
laughed at first just because they're
like it's not seasoned our wedding and
the CW cheese with up there yeah but you
know what it looks really good so I'm
excited to check that out yeah
yep so watch it with me tonight I'll be
live tweeting yeah another trailer that
we saw this week was for a wrinkle in
time and it looks phenomenal
it looks like they're really putting
some budget into this one as well I was
I the only one that saw the original
movie I still own like I don't know it's
okay thank you I think it's a it was a
bit of a mess for me that's saying
something because my copy of a wrinkle
in time growing up had pages falling out
of the book ends I love that book I love
that very why this is so excited to see
it translate it into a better thing -
looks phenomenal
absolutely so I'm very excited to check
out I think we all are something that we
got this week though wasn't quite a
trailer but we got our first little clip
of the
new jurassic world fallen kingdom colin
trevorrow tweeted out an 8-second six
seconds something like that clip of
Chris Pratt's character playing with a
baby laughter it was so he's like
purring it looks like a cat almost he's
playing with it and it was just a little
clip that we got not much explained but
we are gonna have to wait until June 4th
at June of 2018 so hopefully we'll get a
real trailer soon right now we just kind
of got a little clip um in other news
this week Neil Gaiman and Anansi boys is
finally getting the radio drama it
deserves hey I got a radio drama of like
maybe 2005 or so but it was one hour and
Neil himself was not pleased with it he
was very angry about the whole thing it
was a poor adaptation but now with the
popularity of some of his other works
coming into being they decided to give
it another go
and this time it's going to be a
six-part radio drama on BBC Radio 4 I
believe and that's actually starting
right around Christmas so if you are in
you know the British area I don't want
to take a listen to that I'm sure it'll
be good now that it has Neil's blessing
and the time commitment it's hard to
shove a bunch of information into a
small absolutely yeah other big news
this week that I'm really excited for
Mystery Science Theater 3000 is renewed
officially for another season well this
past season was super stud and loved it
and I've loved Felicia Day I don't know
so I'm never very excited that they will
be back with more robots and more antics
and more terrible terrible terrible
films I don't know if some of this
audience likes it I don't you like that
film so that's something the Chairman
want some audio
I don't know you mean to that yeah so
I'm very excited it's going to be coming
back we need we need more okay yeah
probably even more excited though is the
announcement that Harley Quinn is gonna
be getting her own animated series yeah
it's more than josh who is an idea is
going to be on it with her so it's gonna
be hard sided yeah suck on that Joker
you got the whole cinematic universe and
everyone wants to do like your origin
and all your movies guess what not here
yeah I mean one of the things that I
thought was interesting about it too is
that they were billing it as an adult
yeah action comedy series so it's not
going to be a kid-friendly it sounds
like television animated series it's
gonna be on the DC streaming service so
now we know a couple of things that are
gonna be on the DC streaming service
whenever that debuts in 2018 yeah still
have no word don't know what I wanted
that but it will be happy yeah we also
don't have any word of who's hasit as
heartily oh yeah Margot Robbie in the
Cinematic Universe I really like her but
no word on who's going to be doing the
voice-over so we can look forward to
some casting news in the future right I
mean who do you do Tara Strong Margot
Robbie Tara Strong has done a fantastic
just a phenomenal job mm-hmm of all the
voice work that she does man she's got a
great list of things right but also
maybe it's time to pass on the torch if
they're doing a new design if they're
doing classic Harley I'm sure a lot of
people would be upset if they don't you
sir
but here's the time to find someone new
some rush you know who knows mm-hmm yeah
yeah we'll just have to see and wait on
the casting news for that something
that's happening today
tonight on a computer screen near you
maybe even this very computer screen
watching this maybe screen beds is going
to be having an auction for a whole
bunch of different Parks and Rec props
the official props from Parks and Rec
they had a couple of really fun small
pieces that I think a lot of people will
be able to bid on there was
so mouse rat t-shirts the word with perd
mugs snake juice bottle oh my gosh so it
seems like the price point starts at
about $25 for most of the bids which is
very doable for some of us you don't
have a ton of money but would like a
little piece of Parks and Rec history
and part of the proceeds are going to
the LA Conservation Corps which helps
struggling use out so it's kind of
Leslie Knope approved there that some of
the profits are going to be supporting
that organization not to park
sorry pony oh that's so exciting I'll go
check that out um so what since you're
going to be live-tweeting the crisis
episode where can people find you on
social media well you can find me on
Twitter at Heather ruse Instagram at a
truce or twitch twitch TV slash how
their roofs awesome and you can always
find me at Facebook at Anna weed
wherever else at awesome Ayanna you can
also check me on this week's top 5 so if
you're not already planning on checking
that out make sure to top top check it
out because it's a it's a really
important topic I feel very strongly
about what could it be I do not know
awesome well that's gonna be it from us
here guys if you have anything to add
that we missed this week let us know in
the comments down below and otherwise we
will catch you next week in the meantime
beam us up
[Applause]
you